sieht so der nächste winter aus in
diesem video schauen wir auf die
deutsche erdgasversorgung und klären wie
kommt das gas in die haushalte welche
rolle spielen die gasspeicher und warum
hilft konsequentes gas sparen
[Musik]
bis das gas in unseren wohnungen und
häusern ankommt hat es meist einen
langen weitverzweigten weg hinter sich
durch bis zu ein meter vierzig dicke
stahlrohre wird es über weite strecken
quer durch die republik und ins ausland
transportiert im fern- netz fast 40.000
kilometer ist es lang der transport des
gases funktioniert durch hohen druck und
damit der aufrechterhalten werden kann
wird das gas an verdichterstationen
immer wieder komprimiert dieses vernetzt
ist außerdem mit druck regel anlagen
gekoppelt in ihnen wird der gasdruck
verringert damit das erdgas in das weit
verzweigte verteiler netz eingespeist
werden kann in dünneren rohren aus stahl
oder kunststoff wird es dann mit
deutlich weniger druck weiter
transportiert
das gesamte leitungsnetz kommt in
deutschland auf 500 11.000 kilometer es
würde locker bis zum mond reichen der
ist rund 400.000 kilometer von der erde
entfernt
in die haushalte strömt das gas dann mit
deutlich unter einem baum in vielen
haushalten gibt es zusätzliche
sicherheitssysteme um das unfälle zu
vermeiden und genau diese
sicherungssysteme könnten zu einem
kritischen punkt bei der gasversorgung
werden bei starkem unter oder über druck
könnte ein schließmechanismus in der
gaszufuhr ausgelöst werden der kann
unter umständen dann nur durch
fachpersonal wieder gelöst werden
die bundesnetzagentur als oberster
wächter über das gasnetz wird also alles
dafür tun druck probleme durch das
mangel zu vermeiden
eine echte herausforderung ist das
gasnetz insgesamt doch
privatwirtschaftlich organisiert mehr
als 700 netzbetreiber und 900
gasanbieter müssen unter einen hut
gebracht werden und bei dieser aufgabe
kommen auch die ebenfalls
privatwirtschaftlich organisierten
speicher ins spiel
[Musik]
deutschland verfügt über das viert
größte speichervolumen nach den usa der
ukraine und russland rund 50
unterirdische erdgasspeicher stehen zur
verfügung als poren und kavernen
speicher
rohren speicher bestehen aus porösen
gesteinsschichten meist kalk oder
sandstein darüber sorgen dass
undurchlässig geschichten zum beispiel
ton dafür dass das gas unter der erde
bleibt
tavernen speicher sind riesige
künstliche hohlräume in salzstöcken
um erdgas zu lagern wird es gefiltert
verdichtet und dann mit großem druck in
den speicher gepresst dabei entsteht
überdruck der es leichter macht das
erdgas später wieder an die oberfläche
zu holen in einer förderanlage wird es
dann erwärmt und in trocken turm
entwässert bevor es in die
versorgungsnetze eingespeist wird
die gasspeicher spielen eine wichtige
rolle bei der versorgungssicherheit und
preisstabilität
bei regulären gasfluss dienen sie
hauptsächlich als puffer um vor allem im
winter schwankungen beim verbrauch für
heizung und warmwasser auszugleichen und
den druck im netz stabil zu halten
auch bei der stromproduktion kann mit
hilfe der gasspeicher schnell und
flexibel auf schwankungen zum beispiel
durch die erneuerbaren energien reagiert
werden und mit ihnen können
lieferausfälle überbrückt werden
dazu müssen die speicher bei ausreichend
gefüllt sein in den letzten jahren waren
sie im sommer durchschnittlich zu etwa
zwei dritteln gefüllt zum teil sogar
deutlich geringer das ist kein problem
so lange genug erdgas ins netz läuft
aber die lage ist angespannt
deshalb hat die bundesregierung ein
gasspeicher gesetz und eine verordnung
erlassen
bis zum ersten oktober müssen die
füllstände bei 85% bis zum ersten
november bei 95 prozent liegen
wären alle speicher deutschlands
randvoll hätte man eine gasmenge von
rund 24 milliarden kubikmetern zur
verfügung allein damit könnten wir uns
bei durchschnittlichem verbrauch fast
drei wintermonate mit gas versorgen wenn
wir unseren verbrauch reduzieren sogar
länger
außerdem strömt nach wie vor auch noch
gas aus norwegen und den niederlanden
mittlerweile sogar mehr als jemals zuvor
aber auch alternativen die lng oder
biogas helfen uns durch den winter
das den privathaushalten die rund 31
prozent des erdgases verbrauchen das gas
ausgeht kalten experten deshalb für
unwahrscheinlich
ein gas mangel würde voraussichtlich
erst mal die industrie treffen sie hat
mit etwa 37 prozent einen etwas größeren
verbrauch wenn dann produktionen ruhen
müssen betrifft uns das langfristig
allerdings alle jobs geraten in gefahr
waren fehlen lieferketten leiden und die
preise steigen weiter deshalb hilft vor
allem das sparen
[Musik]
das sparen ergibt also sinn egal wie die
versorgungssituation ist es wird dazu
führen dass sich die gasspeicher
schneller füllen und gegebenenfalls
sogar eine konstante reserve vorhanden
ist viele städte und gemeinden haben
bereits gehandelt heitz intensive
hallenbäder bleiben in den sommermonaten
geschlossen oder senken die
wassertemperatur behörden und ämter
schicken ihr personal in teilen wieder
ins home office so müssen weniger büros
geheizt werden allerdings diese heitz
rechnung funktioniert nur wenn die
mitarbeiter im home office in ohnehin
geheizten räumen arbeiten müssen dafür
zusätzlich räume geheizt werden wäre das
nur eine umverteilung der kosten auf die
privathaushalte doch gerade die sollen
ja beim sparen helfen auch für das
eigene portemonnaie deshalb noch ein
paar tipps
die heizung nicht nur warten sondern
optimal einstellen lassen eine gut
eingestellte heizung verbraucht bis zu
15 prozent weniger energie
raumtemperatur senken schon ein grad
weniger spart sechs prozent energie und
damit auch kosten
und in sachen warmwasser stadt baden
lieber duschen am besten mit wasser spar
duschkopf bei kurzer durch zeit und
nicht zu heißem wasser kommt ganz schön
was zusammen bis zu 30 warmwasser können
so gespart werden und das bedeutet auch
wieder deutlich geringere kosten